اختتمت قمه بغداد اعمالها في ظل حضور
محدود لقاده الدول العربيه وببيان شمل
جمله مقررات لم تشكل خرقا كبيرا على مستوى
العمل العربي المشترك القمه عقدت في عراق
يعاني من انقسام سياسي ومشاكل داخليه وامن
هش وما يوصف بنفوذ ايراني جمله معطيات تشك
العراق على قياده العالم العربي في ظرف
دقيق مليء
بالتحديات نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
عنوان
رئيسيين ما دلاله المشاركه المحدوده
للقاده العرب في القمه وهل هذه القمه هي
التي يريدها العرب وكيف سيقود العراق
العمل العربي خلال العام المقبل وهل
بامكان الخاصره الرخوه قياده
العرب
انهت قمه بغداد او قمه الربيع العربي
اعمالها دون ان توفر اجوبه على سلسله من
الاسئله العالقه والمرتبطه بالملفات
الاشكاليه في العالم العربي التقرير
التالي يرصد الامال التي عقدت على القمه
والحصاد الذي خرجت
به التم شمل القاده العرب وانفض خلال
ساعات قليله غادروا القاعه التاركين
ورائهم جمله اسئله لم تجد اجوبتها الشافيه
صحيح ان الرموز تكثفت في القمه موفره
اجابات ارضت في الشكل اطرافا لكنها خيبت
في المضمون امال اخرين عادت بغداد الى
العرب قال المضيف العراقي عادت الى عروبه
تبدو جامعه ولا تمانع اطلاقا ان يتراس
جلساتها جلال الطالباني لكن هل عاد العراق
بالفعل عربيه الهوى والهويه بمجرد توافد
القاده الى عاصمته وهل تراجع النفوذ فيه
وهل اغلقت بوابات الوطن العربي الشرقيه في
وجه تمدد الاطراف الاقليميه النفوذ
الايراني لن ينحسر عن العراق لانه
بالضروره قائم في ظل معطيات تاريخيه
وحضاريه وسياسيه ضمن التحالف القائم بين
الحكومه الراهنه في العراق وبين الايران
ومن ثم فعندما تعقد هذه القمه العربيه
و توصف من قبل القاده العرب بانها عوده
العراق الى حاضنته العربيه والقوميه فذلك
يعني انه سوف يخسر حاضرته الاقليميه
المتمثله في ايران سوريا الحاضر همها غاب
السقف المرتفع عن المقررات التي تخصها
حاول العرب تدوير الزوايا فتما هوا في
قرارهم مع كوفي عنان ونقاطه الست الى حد
التطابق الكلي وهنا رمى العرب الملف
السوري في الملعب الدولي مخافه تفجر القمه
لكن مفارقه التدويل تكمل في ان مبادره
المبعوث الدولي لا تطالب الرئيس السوري
بما سبق للجامعه ان اقرته اي تفويض
صلاحياته الى نائبه قراته في اطار ما وقع
من اتفاق مع وزير الخارجيه الروسي من اجل
خلق دفعه في الامم المتحده في مجلس الامن
لقرار دولي اذا هذا الاطار الذي مهد
لمبادره كوفي عنان ودعم مبادره كوفي عنان
هو الذي يفسر موقف القمه الان عراقيا
انتهت قمه بغداد وهواجس اهل الرافدين لم
تتبدد نجح العراق في الاختبار الامني لكن
دون نجاح في اختبار المصالحه الوطنيه
عوائق عده ابرزها المحاصصه والفساد وتغييب
اطياف عراقيه مختلفه عن دائره صنع القرار
الوطني في قمه استثنائيه في الزمان
والمكان جاءت النتائج متواضعه في المضمون
لا خروقات كبرى سجلت ولا قرارات حاسمه
سطرت في قمه الربيع العربي مازن ابراهيم
الجزيره
بغداد حلقتنا المباشره هذه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر لهذه الليله والتي تاتيكم من
مقر انعقاد القمه في العاصمه العراقيه
يشاركنا في النقاش فيها كل من زياد الذرب
من عمان عضو البرلمان العراقي عن قائمه
العراقيه وعريب الرنتاوي مدير مركز القدس
للدراسات السياسيه ايضا من عمان ومن بغداد
حنان الفتلاوي عضو البرلمان العراقي عن
دوله القانون ارحب بضيوف جميعا وابدا معك
سيد عريب الرنتاوي من عمان اولا بماذا
يمكن تفسير هذا التمثيل المتدني لعدد كبير
من الدول العربيه في هذه
القمه يعني هي ليست المره الاولى
بالمناسبه التي تعقد فيها القمم العربيه
بتمثيل متدني هذا جزء من فلكلور وتراث
القمم العربيه والسبب الرئيس في ظنه كان
في السابق كما هو اليوم حاله الانقسام
شردم في المواقف العربيه حيال جمله
الملفات الرئيسيه التي تواجهها القمم
العربيه هناك ربما بعض الاسباب الاضافيه
فيما خص هذه القمه تحديدا وتتصل بالعلاقه
غير الطبيعيه بين العراق وبعض دول الخليج
بشكل خاص شهدنا في الطريق الى بغداد جمله
من الصفقات
والمقايضة يب بعض المسؤولين الكبار
واستبدلوا عن ذلك بسفراء ومندوبين يعني
بمستوى تمثيلي منخفض بهذا المعنى لكن يعني
في الحقيقه النقطه الجوهريه في هذا
الموضوع ان رياح الثوره والتغيير في
العالم العربي لم تصل بعد الى الجامعه الى
القمه العربيه الى النظام الرسمي العربي
معظم الدول الاعضاء لم يشملها التغيير من
جهه والدول التي شملها التغيير لم ترتب
اوراقها وبيتها الداخلي بعد وبالتالي يجب
الحكم على قمه ب بغداد بنفس المعايير التي
حكم بها على القمم العربيه السابقه وهي
انها لا لا تدرا ضرا ولم تجلب نفعا هكذا
كان الحال مع قمه سرت قبلها ومع كثير من
القمم العربيه وفي ظني ان قمه بغداد لن
تكون خروجا عن هذا السياق قمه عاديه في
زمن استثنائي خطير والسبب في ذلك هو هزال
النظام الرسمي العربي حتى الان هزال
النظام الاقليمي العربي عدم في الحقيقه
قدره الجامعه العربيه على مواكبه ربيع
العرب وثوراته وانتفاضات و وحركه التغيير
الشامله التي شهدتها بعض الدول العربيه
يبدو اننا ما زلنا بحاجه لان ننتظر بضع
سنوات اضافيه حتى نرى تغييرا جدريا في
النظام السياسي الرسمي
العربي طيب سيد زياد الضرب في ايضا الى اي
مدى يقلل هذا الحضور المتدني من اهميه
المقررات التي صدرت عن هذه
القمه نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في
البدايه احييك وحيي ضيفي الكريمين ومشاهدي
قناه الجزيره
الفضائيه المهم في هذه القمه هو عوده
العراق الى اسرته العربيه الاصيله والمهم
في هذه القمه التمثيل لجميع الدول بغض
النظر عن وجود رؤساء مثلوا دولهم
ام وزراء ام مندوبين
ام رؤساء وزراء في هذا المؤتمر كل يمثل
دولته وهذه القمه في هذا الظرف الاستثنائي
اي كنا نامل ان تكون فاتحه خير على العراق
وعلى العراقيين وان توقف النفوذ الايراني
في العراق في المنطقه
برمتها كنا نامل ان تكون ادانه لهذه
التدخلات من قبل جهات خارجيه في في كثير
من الاقطار العربيه في سوريا في لبنان في
اليمن في البحرين في كل حتى في العراق
وكنا نامل ان يطلب القاده العرب المؤتمرين
في بغداد من السيد بشار الاسد بترك السلطه
والتنحي عنها وايقاف نزيف الدم نعم القم
ركزت في كثير من محاورها وجميع الخطابات
لرؤساء ركزت على الملف السوري
وتركت الملف السوري على مبادره كوفي عنان
بتنحي السيد بشار الاسد عن السلطه
و استبداله بنائبه وبعدها سيتم على قرار
ما حدث في اليمن ان تكون هناك انتخابات
ولكن على العموم نامل من من الدول العربيه
والدول الخليجيه بالذات ان يكون لها حضور
بعد القمه في في العراق في التمثيل
الدبلوماسي والحضور على الساحه العراقيه
في اعاده اعمار العراق وفي
التواجد السياسي على على الساحه
العراقيه دكتوره حنان الفتلاوي حكومه غير
قادره على تحقيق التوافق بين
اركانها بمعنى اطراف العمليه السياسيه هل
بامكانها تحقيق التوافق في العالم العربي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بدايه تحيه طيبه
لك ولضيوفك الكرام ويؤسفني لم اسمع حديث
الضيفين الزميلين الاخرين وبالتالي من
الصعب ان ارد على ما تحدثوا به ولكن ساعلق
على المقدمه حقيقه يؤسفني ويؤلمني ان يتم
الحديث عن العراق بهذه الطريقه عراق مهد
الحضارات عراق مولد الكتابه العراق مولد
القانون عراق العرب حاضنه العرب نتحدث عن
العراق اليوم وكانه ال خاصر الرخوه يؤسفني
ان يكون الحديث عن العراق بهذه الطريقه
القضيه الاخرى اللي اشرت لها بالمقدمه
والتي وردت في اسئلتك للضيوف الاخرين
التمثيل المتدني او التمثيل المنخفض انا
لا اتصور ان اليوم التمثيل في القمه
العربيه والعراقيه هو متدني او منخفض الكل
يتذكر القمم السابقه كم كان حضور عدد
الرؤساء الذين حضروا القمه الاخيره الكل
يتذكر اذا كان كانوا تسعه ف بالنتيجه
اليوم في قمه بغداد وقمه العرب في ظل هذه
الظروف بعد التحولات الاخ خيره في الدول
العربيه بعد الوضع الذي يمر فيه العراق
بعد الانسحاب الامريكي في ظل الظروف
الامنيه في ظل المراهنات على افشال هذه
القمه الكل كان يتحدث عن افشالها والكل
حاول تاجيلها والكل راهن على ان العراق
غير قادر على اداره هذه القمه ولكن العراق
بشعبه بحكومته بتكاتف الجميع اليوم استطاع
ان يثبت ل للعرب جميعا لو سمحت لي ربما
اهميه العدد هنا تكمن في انها ربما
تترجم تحقيق رجاء العراق بالعوده الى
الحاضنه العربيه وعوده العرب ايضا نعم لو
سمحت لو سمحتي لي هو هذا اللي اريد اوضحه
اهميه القمه للعراق شعب العراق وحكومه
العراق ليس بالمقررات التي ستصدر عن القمه
وانما هي علامه لتعافي العراق وعودت الى
عروبته عودته الى محيط العربي عودته ليكون
عضو فعال
ويكون يعني اساس في المنظومه العربيه هذا
هو الهدف من القمه ان تعقد في مثل هذا
التوقيت في بغداد وليس بمقررات القمه
اليوم ليست القمه الاولى هي التي تعقد في
بغداد هذه القمه الثالثه والش اي قمه
استطاعت ان تحل مشاكل العرب اي قمه انجزت
ما ما عجزت عنه هذه القمه التمثيل كان
جيدا لا بل اكثر من جيد
وممتاز الاحاديث والخطابات التي القيت
كانت ايجابيه ش كيف تفسرين الغياب غياب
بعض الدول وليس الكل البعض مثل على على
مستوى رئيس والبعض مثل على مستوى رئيس
وزراء والبعض مثل بمستوى وزير خارجيه
والبعض مثل بمستوى سفير نعم يؤسفنا كان
طموحنا ان يكون تمثيل الاخوه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ان يكون تمثيلا اكبر
ولكن هذا شانه لا يستطيع العراق ان يفرض
على جهه اخرى ان تحدد مستوى تمثيلها
التمثيل المنخفض اذا شاء لنا ان تسميه لا
يعود للعراق هو احترام للمنظومه العربيه
احترام للقضايا العربيه انا حينما ما
احترم قضيه امثلها بتمثيل عالي حينما لا
احترم قضيه مؤكد لا يهمني مستوى التمثيل
فبالنسبه للعراق الرؤساء الذين حضروا
شرفوا العراق وكان مرحب بهم والجميع ابدى
ارتياحه وامتنانا للاستعدادات الكل لم يكن
احد يتوقع انه في مثل الوضع الامني في
العراق ان تجري الترتيبات والمسائل بهذه
الطريقه انا اتصور القمه ناجحه وليس
بشهادتها نحن كعراقيين وانما بشهاده من
يريد الخير للعراق انها كانت ناجحه على كل
الاصعده وعلى كل المستويات سواء مستوى
التمثيل او مستوى الخطاب العربي او مستوى
القضايا التي تبنتها القمه اليوم الارهاب
قضيه مصيريه تهم كل الدول لا تهم العراق
فقط التعاون الاقتصادي شيء اساسي ويفترض
ان يركز عليه قضيه سوريا الكل اليوم
القضيه سوريا تحظى باهتمام كل الدول
العربيه فبالنهاية
حضور اليوم الوفد الكويتي كان رائعا
الخطاب الكويتي كان رائعا وهذا شيء مهم
بالنسبه للشعب العراقي نامل ان نفتح نوع
جديد من العلاقات مع اشقائنا العرب طالما
اتهمنا بابتعاد عن العرب ولا نتحمل هذه
المسؤوليه العرب ابتعدوا عنا اليوم نحن
فتحنا ايدينا وفتحنا اذرع للعرب ليعودوا
لنا اخوه واشقاء نتعاون معهم في محاربه
الارهاب نتعاون معهم في ملفات اقتصاديه
تعود بالخير لكل الشعوب الفائده للعراق
فائده معنويه اكثر م ما هي فائده ماديه
العراق ليس بلدا فقيرا ويامل ان يحصل على
عطف او مساعده من احد على الاطلاق طموحنا
ان تعود علاقتنا باشقا اننا العرب حتى لا
نعطي مبرر للاخرين لاتهام باننا نتبع دوله
اخرى او هناك نفوذ لدوله اخرى يفترض
بالعرب مددنا ايدينا لهم ان يمدوا ايديهم
هم بالمقابل للعراق ويعيدوا احتضانه ليكون
جزء فاعل ومؤثر العراق سبق دول كثيره في
تجربه الديمقراطيه بما لها وما عليها
بسلبياتها وايجابياتها اليوم نتحدث عن
تجربه عراقيه لا اقول تجربه باهره ومضيئه
لكن فيها سلبيات وفيها ايجابيات نامل ان
لا يقع اخواننا العرب التجارب الفتيه في
الدول الاخرى نامل ان لا تمر بممر فيه
العراق نامل ان لا يكون هناك شحن طائفي
بين الاطراف الاولى نامل ان لا تسرق
الثورات مثل ما حصل في العراق على كل كيف
سيقود العراق العمل العربي المشترك في
المرحله المقبله سيكون هذا محور نقاشنا في
الجزء الثاني من حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر لهذه الليله نعود لكم بعد فاصل قصير
ارجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في حلقتنا
التي تتناول مقررات قمه بغداد وقدره
العراق على قياده المرحله المقبله السييد
زياد الذرب في عمان يعني الحكومه العراقيه
بشهاده قادتها
ا تعاني مشاكل امنيه وسياسيه
داخليه هل هي قادره مع ذلك على حل مشاكل
العرب في المرحله
القادمه نعم العراق وليد جديد يعني وخرج
من مرحله انتقاليه وهو الان في مرحله مهمه
بعد جلاء القوات الامريكيه من
العراق لم يتعافى بعد هناك مشاكل داخليه
هناك
انقسامات وهناك اقصاء وتهميش لمجموعه
وللفئات معينه من الشعب هذا موجود ولكن
انا في تصوري جميع هذه المشاكل بامكان
العراق ان يتغلب عليها في المرحله القادمه
اذا ما كانت هناك صدق في النوايا و تقارب
في وجهات النظر بين الفرقاء
السياسيين تنفيذ الاتفاقيات السابقه فيما
بينهم ممكن الجميع يتعاون في سبيل انجاح
هذه المهمه والمهمه الصعبه هي في في غايه
الصعوبه وخاصه على العراق الوليد ولكن
العراق قادر على يتغلب على هذه المصاعب
اذا كانت هناك صدق في النوايا
وتوحيد الاراء
و ان يكون هناك القرار مشترك فيما بينه
العراق على مر على مر الدهور والزمان
الماضي كان
بامكانه ان يقود العرب الى الى مرحله
جديده ومرحله ممكن ان تكون هذه المرحله
المقبله كفيله بان تعيد العراق الى ما كان
عليه في في الرياده وفي مقدمه الدول
العربيه
للاسف لا اسمع بشكل واضح جدا اصوات ضيوفي
خاصه ضيوفي وطبعا ضيوفي في في عمان لذلك
لا استطيع لا التعقيب ولا المقاطعه اذا
استلزم الامر ومع ذلك استمر واتوجه الى
عريبه الرنتاوي
الموضوع السوري استاذ الرنتاوي والذي طرح
بشكل
يعني كبير على بيان القمه الختامي والذي
بشانه الحكومه العراقيه التزمت منذ بدايه
الثوره السوريه موقف ضبابي والتزمت الصمت
في كثير من الاحيان كيف لها ان تتعاطى مع
هذا الملف الشائك
ومع يعني المقررات بشانه والي تنفيذ مثلا
خطه كوفي عنان او المبادره
العربيه يعني دعيني اقول ابتداء ان الملف
السوري خرج من اليد العربيه هو الان ملف
مدول وهو الان في ايدي كوفي عنان ومجلس
الامن واصدقاء سوريا والامم المتحده وغير
ذلك يعني مبادره كوفي عنان رسمت سقفا لقمه
بغداد لم نكن نتوقع على الاطلاق ولقد قلنا
ذلك وكتبنا قبل القمه بايام طويله ان سقف
القمه فيما خص المشهد السوري قد تقرر
مسبقا وعليه فلن يكون هناك اي مفاجاه حيال
الملف السوري في القمه قمه بغداد هذا اولا
ثانيا فيما خص القياده العراقيه جرت في
الطريق الى القمه جمله اتصالات بين بعض
الاطراف العربيه والعراق خصوصا الخليجيه
السعوديه وقطر على وجه التحديد من اجل
يعني اجراء بعض يعني المراجعات للمواقف في
هذا المجال لاحظنا العراق في الاونه
الاخيره بدا يتخلى عن تحفظاته حيال
المواقف العربيه من اجل تسهيل انعقاد
القمه هو قبل بالمبادره العربيه وهو انتقد
بسلوك النظام السوري واستخدامه المفرط
للقوه و تحدث عن تاقير الاصلاحات واطلق
مبادره اي ان العراق حاول وهو يمهد للقمه
العربيه ان يرضي بعض الاطراف العربيه
ولكنه يبدو على ما يبدو لم يرضيها بما
يكفي لذلك لم يكن تمثيل لها كافن في هذه
القمه ثم سمعنا عن مقايضات بمعنى من
المعاني بمعنى ان نلتزم بالسقف الدولي في
موضوع سوريا مقابل عدم طرح موضوع البحرين
على سبيل المثال على القمه العربيه وهذا
كان بهدف تشجيع بعض الاطراف الخليجيه من
اجل المشاركه ورفع مستوى تمثيلها في هذا
المجال علما باننا نعرف ان الموضوع
البحريني موضوع حساس بالنسبه لقطاع كبير
من الراي العام العراقي السؤال الاهم في
الحقيقه في هذا المجال متى كانت رئاسه
القمه في العمل العربي المشترك هي التي
تقود هذا العمل العربي المشترك هل قاد
حسني مبارك عملا عربيا مشتركا فعالا هل ح
سهر على تنفيذ قرارات القمم العربيه التي
عقدت في القاهره هل فعلت زين العابدين بن
بن علي شيئا كهذا فيما خص مقررات قمه تونس
وغيرها سمحت لي واعتذر منك لانه
الاتصالات سيئه هذا المساء وضيف اختي
الدكتوره حنان الفتلاوي لا تستمع اليك
جيدا وتكتفي بالنظر اليها
للاسف اتوجه الى الكتوره حنان معي هنا في
الهواء الطلق في بغداد وانهي
معك لايران ملفات عالقه مع عدد من الدول
العربيه وهي في نظر بعض الاطراف ساحه نفوذ
لايران كيف يمكنها التوفيق في التعاطي مع
الطرفين العرب والايراني في هذه الظروف
الاستثنائيه يعني من سوء حظي لم اسمع ردود
الضيفين الاخرين وبالتالي ساجيب على سؤالك
طبعا الكل يتهم اليوم العراق بانه ساحه
للنفوذ الايراني نعم بالفتره الماضيه بسبب
الاحداث الامنيه بسبب الاحتلال بسبب ملفات
كثيره
بسبب الشحن الطائفي الذي حصل اعطى مجال
لنفوذ دول كثيره وليس لايران بالنتيجه
مشاكل ايران مع دول تحلها ايران اليوم
العراق ليس تتابعا لاحد العراق يامل ان
يرتبط بعلاقه متوازنه مع كل دول الجوار
ايران دوله جاره دوله مسلمه نامل ان تكون
علاقتنا معها علاقه متوازنه لا نريد ان
نعيد ما قام به النظام السابق سبب ماسي
للعراق ويران بحربه اللام مبرره التي حصلت
مع ايران و راح ضحيتها الاف من الشباب
العراقي الابرياء الذين لا ذنب لهم نفس
الشيء نفس المغامره كررها مع الدوله
الشقيقه الكويت وبالنتيجه ايضا سبب ماسي
لكل البلدين وايضا اليوم ما زلنا الى
اليوم ندفع ثمن ملفات قام بها النظام
السابق بمغامرات ايران لديها مشاكل مع بعض
الدول ولكن العراق ليس بتابع لايران ايران
تحل مشاكلها وم ملفاتها مع الدول الاخرى
بعيدا عن العراق وبمعزل عن العراق نعم
يوجد نفوذ ايراني ولكن بقوه الدوله
العراقيه حينما تقوى الدوله وحينما تبنى
دوله المؤسسات بعوده العراق الى محيط
العربي بعوت ليلعب دور اساسي في المنظومه
العربيه انا اتصور هذا النفوذ سينحسر
تدريجيا وهو اليوم واجب على الدول العربيه
ان تعمل مع العراق تتعاون مع العراق اليوم
الخطاب اللي سمعناه بالقمه تضامن عربي
تعاون عربي ملفات اقتصاديه مشتركه بين
الدول العربيه هذه هي المدخل لتقليل
النفوذ الايراني والابتعاد عن المشاكل
الايرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتوره حنان
الفتلاوي كما اشكر من عمان ضيفي كل من
السيد عر الرنتاوي
وزياد الذرب وبهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخ خبر
جاتكم مباشره من العاصمه العراقيه بغداد
نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء
خبر جديد تحيه لكم اينما كنتم الى
اللقاء m